[Musique]
si nous restons sans rien faire nos
sociétés vont s'effondrer pas seulement
aux états unis mais au mexique en aussi
en chine en europe
[Musique]
la course première c'est qu'on a on a
fabriqué ce que j'appelle l'effet clown
défaut aliments des aliments qu'on a
artificialisés au niveau des qualités
sensorielles c'est-à-dire goûts leurs
armes et textures et l'artificialisation
de cette matrice au niveau sensoriel
nous pousse à consommer plus que de
raison la question de fond c'est pas la
transformation manche transformé depuis
la nuit des temps
la vraie question c'est quel degré de
transformation et acceptables pour la
santé
[Musique]
oh
parce qu'on nous répète tout le temps
si vous voulez maigrir et au delà du
sport suivez un régime est là ou si vous
faites ça vous y arriverez il ya aussi
ce qu'on appelle des déserts
alimentaires les industries ne sont pas
forcément responsable mais c'est par
exemple dans certains endroits les
snacks qui sont proposés c'est que des
distributeurs de produits transformés
ça peut être la restauration collective
ou trop le choix des x 50 % de leurs
résultats à transformer à midi donc là
c'est difficile de faire autrement
et puis vous avez des heureux même
urbaine d'où le rôle des architectes qui
fait qu'on peut se promener pour faire
ses achats pendant de plusieurs
kilomètres sans trouver une offre de
produits frais
[Musique]
hier j'ai une tante way qui est morte du
diabète
c'est dans ma famille on lui a coupé un
orteil et et puis le pied et pour finir
toute la jambe sûreté mais c'était ma
tante quand on parle de diabète
la plupart des gens pensent à des
amputations qui est un but il est des
piqûres normil où sort un cholet je ne
veux pas que mes enfants subissant
[Musique]
l'obésité d'abord il faut bien
comprendre c'est une maladie chronique
non transmissibles ou au contraire des
maladies infectieuses qui se
transmettent comme avec les virus et il
ya de plus en plus d'obèses parce qu'on
vit dans des environnements de plus en
plus haut des zones génique
alors je m'explique c'est quoi un
environnement obésogène hic c'est un
environnement qu'il ya plusieurs
dimensions qui favorise l'obésité alors
que le pilier numéro un c'est évidemment
la mauvaise alimentation est ce qu on
voit bien que dans des pays qui réunit
alimentation traditionnelle et qu'ils se
sont mis à nous faut seulement être
atteints de forme et on voit l'obésité
apparaître de manière coréenne ensuite
il ya la baisse de l'activité physique
qui joue aussi un rôle très important la
pollution environnementale
le stress le manque de sommeil et enfin
la génétique
on peut espérer que justement c'est une
crise qui permette aux gens d'avoir une
prise de conscience sur la pac de ce
qu'ils mangent sur leur santé et sur la
lame est en général j'espère que ça
permettra d'avancer plus vite dans pour
des systèmes alimentaires plus durable
et surtout le respect de la biodiversité